Hey! What's up guys, it's Pewdiepie, and this is my family. (Yes, even the president OMG)
[Anime Intro Song]
Hello everybody, Mar...
We got some new members here. I know what you're thinking, oh, "he's gone crazy," huh
I have real friends in real life, okay. These are these are just,
(whispers) for sex.
We got Trump. Trump in the back
[American National Anthem]
Mr. President, thank you for joining us today. Thank you, thank you . We also have Danny. Danny is here, Danny.
You'll think I'm out of ideas?
[Laughs]
No. Give me an idea Danny, give me an idea right now. [Danny] Why don't you check out some subreddits
pewdiepie. All right subreddits, we're gonna go through
subreddits. That's fun. Hey, not bad Danny. Does anyone know like a weird subreddit? Like I'm not
[Laughs] You should watch old ladies baking pies.
Good idea. Wait, you gotta be 18 to check this one out. W-why is it so sexual? Ew.
Ew!
No.
No guy, what is wrong with- ew!
[I] don't like that. [I] don't- ew. Alright  does anyone else have any better idea than that? I'll take anything.
I'm desperate.
[Markiplier] "Dragons fucking cars."
What? Say that again.
[Markiplier] Dragons fucking cars .
What kind of, what kind of shit are you into, Markiplier?
Okay. Dr- that's a Reddit.
That's a subreddit, okay. It can't be that bad. I want to just cry. I don't-
Why would you do that, to a dragon? I used to love dragons. Mark you're out.
I'm sorry Mark, you're out.
Go into the ceiling. I don't-
You're going to the ceiling with the rest of them, okay? You can come back
when you don't suggest this God-awful-
bullshit. Does anyone else
have any better ideas, than dragons fucking car?
[Phone rings]
Jack? "PewDiePie mate, you should look at the Kellog's subreddit." Okay. Kellog's Gone Wild. "Even Better."
Okay, let's check "Kellog's Gone Wild" out.
How does it get so big? How does it get so big!? How does an asshole get that big? Does anyone
have a better idea!?
[Emma] "I have an idea." Emma what do you got? "Everyone please subsc-"
No, I'm not going to check out your channel Emma. Trump please I beg, y- just one more suggestion. "Guilty pleasures."
"Guilty pleasure?" What could that be? A subreddit dedicated to guilty pleasures, of music. What's your guilty pleasure Trump?
[Music:"Pon Pon Pon"]
[Trump] It's lit.
I'm not judging. I'm not judging. That's cool. You know, whatever you're into. (whispers) fuckin' weirdo.
Illusion porn! Oh, that's interesting. That's definitely interesting (burps) What the fuck?
What is happening? [Laughs]
It looks so beautiful. Oh my God. [Laughs] What the fuck happened here?
It's a "log dog."
How is no one impressed?
It's a log dog. Hey, uh, so what do you do for a living? "Uh Well, you know, I create titties out of  blankets
with shadows." All right, I need more suggestions. Can someone please help out? For once, can you help out?
I'm dying here, literally. Give me anything. "GifExtra." [Laughs]
Oh, that's cool. Oh yeah, I've seen this one. He punches the Kangaroo. It's fuckin' amazing.
What is he doing? Woah!
[Laughs]
How!? How the fuck did you do that? That's some- amazing editing!
I wish I had that ability to just spawn Connor McGregor, at any time.
[Laughs]
[To Trump] You two are so cute, you know that?
So cute. I ship them, I ship them. Come on guys, come on.
[Starts clapping]
Need some good shit for once. Come on. Come on spit it out. Who said that?
Who said it?
Who was it? Who said "birds with penises?" Who said it? I am not leaving until- Slippy!
Did you say "birds with human penises?" "Yes I did, I like me some dicks on chicks."
What kind of weird shit are you into buddy? All right, let's check it out together, Slippy.
Like the good old days. Don't shit on me please. Why? Why? What the fuck, man?
What the fuck? I gotta check on the good stuff, got it. All right. You're just fuckin' weird. This is all your fault, okay?
It's not my fault, this channel is failing. Okay? It's your fault.
No, not you, Danny. I'm talking to Danny, okay? Come on man, stop. I need something interesting.The Ainsley Harriott
subreddit. Is that Ainsley from the 90s? Damn! He looks so cool.
[Laughs]
He's so cute. This is, "when he bites his lip." I miss him so much.
Ainsley, I missed your smile.
[Sad music starts]
I miss your, laughter.
I miss your, touch.
Please, just go. Just go!
God damn it.
You're not him.
Leave a like if you enjoyed watching this video. Check out another one, over here.
And, remember to leave a like. Have you left a like?
Please leave a like. Please.